what is it doing what is it doing don't  trust these new cause it'll make any  good noise what was that I can't believe  she said that to you so unprofessional  um are you talking to me what did she  say are you talking to me Oh  all the are you talking to Jesus Christ  you're doing to my ribs it's in my ribs  listen I don't have the app so awareness  this is like a smart view  smart vehicle doesn't make any noise  pretty stupid if you ask me OOP you're  talking to me you're talking to me Bow  Wow could you please could you put your  seat belt on this is how this is gonna  work you don't say a word we get along  just fine if you say one more thing and  we'll break your legs put them back  together and break them again I'm gonna  stand yes sir and where do you live  Jesus Christ is wrong with you sit back  there you should have never moved down  here